but I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV
it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on pgan on sensor Netanyahu
doubles down on refusing to accept there
must be a Palestinian state with his
personal popularity plunging his
reputation for security in Ruins as BB
given up on peace will debate a British
trans golfer makes history in the US
security a spot on a prestigious tour
was specifically designed to provide
opportunities for female players is this
golf moving with the times or should
ladies golf mean people who were
actually born
ladies a stargazing Superstar Neil
degrass Tyson returns to uncensored with
a cosmic take on artificial
intelligence live from the news building
in London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
good to be back in our Capital City
Welcome to Pi Morgan uncensored there
could be no meaningful and Lasting peace
in Israel without a two-state solution
that is surely a fundamental fact it
means both sides of Miss intractable
conflict recognize another's right to
exist it means that Palestinians have
the same rights as Israelis enshrined in
law it daes the Flames of burning
resentment which rage across the Middle
East and so much of the Muslim world and
in doing so so it would ultimately make
Israel a safer place but prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu has abandoned all
pretense of a two-state solution with
increasingly asendur rhetoric he's made
it crystal clear that he sees only one
state from The River To The
Sea I clarify that in any arrangement in
the foreseeable future with an accord or
without an accord the state of Israel
must have security control over the
entire territory west of the Jordan
River that's a necessary condition it
clashes with the prin of
sovereignty this weekend Netanyahu
doubled done again President Biden spoke
to him for the first time in a month
emerging optimistically from the phone
call to say a two-state solution is
still possible even with Netanyahu in
charge but then Netanyahu responded by
posting this I will not compromise on
full Israeli security control over all
the territory west of Jordan and this is
contrary to a Palestinian State and the
hardliners in his own party are backing
him to the hilt they say that even
discussing a Palestinian state is
rewarding violence and putting a price
on terror but that is the text butt
rhetoric of an occupying power it's
precisely the dynamic but has
radicalized Palestinians against Israel
there is no moral defense of Hamas and
no justification for its barbaric attack
on October the 7th I made that
repeatedly clear there's also no defense
of calling Palestinians Human animals
claiming there are no innocent civilians
in Gaza all saying the common goal of
all Israelis is to erase Gaza from the
face of the Earth all genuine comments
made by supporters of Netanyahu since
the War Began Netanyahu looks
increasingly like he's clinging to power
and pandering to the hardliners in his
cabinet to keep his job former Israel
Israeli Prime Minister ehu Barak today
told Netanyahu a name of God go warning
that Israel will sink in the Gaza mud
for years to come if he continues to
lead the country protesters today storm
Israeli Parliament to demand netanyahu's
government does more to secure the
return of their loved ones still held
captive by the the very people he vowed
to
eradicate yes Israel must defend itself
every country has that right and Duty
he's right about that but he must also
recognize that the war cannot go on
forever Hamas is both a proponent and a
product of Oppression without freedom
and rights more radicalization will
surely follow one of Israel's most
distinguished leaders once wrote that an
open-ended allout war in Gaza would be
Hollow and self-defeating the Hamas
leaders would come out from their holes
and declare Victory among the ruins he
said who was it that wrote those words
Benjamin
Netanyahu well joining me first to
discuss this is Israeli government
spokesman uh Mark regev Mark regev good
to see you uh and a belated happy New
Year we haven't spoken this year A lot
has happened since we last spoke I have
a simple question following Benjamin
netanyahu's rhetoric in the last few
days which is what gives Israel the
right to believe that it should exercise
this kind of of control over
Palestinians right to have their own
State the right of self-defense the
right of my country to live in security
the fact that we have to base peace on
realities and not some sort of pip dream
and the reality will always be for the
foreseeable future that Israel lives in
a tough neighborhood and any peace
understandings reached that don't take
that into account and aren built solid
on security and an infrastructure of
security no such peace can survive right
but but is this open-ended then is this
forever is Israel's position now a
totally implacable there will never be a
two-state solution because Benjamin
netanyahu's words certainly suggest
that so you've seen and you know that
over the last half decade we've seen
peace break out between Israel and a
series of Arab countries the UAE Bahrain
Morocco
uh you've seen talk of a peace agreement
with Saudi Arabia which the Saudis
despite the current fighting have still
said is is on the table now we believe
as Israel moves and is accepted more and
more by the Arab world and this is
ultimately a very very positive process
that that will also affect Palestinian
opinion and the sort of extremism that
Kamas represents will be destroyed in
this war will be discredited and that'll
give room for moderates and we want to
see the Palestinians join the circle of
Peace but a peace that is based on
reality not on pipe dreams how many
Hamas terrorists do you think you've
killed so there are a couple of hundred
that we killed on our side of the border
on that first terrible day of October
7th and in the the following days
immediately after that Massacre uh we
had to take them out we those people who
invaded our country and so forth and
since the operation in Gaz started we
think over 9,000 of kamasa military figh
is their armed terrorists we we've taken
out and and killed right so less than a
quarter of Hamas is believed false of
36,000 or so uh depending on which
numbers you believe but my point being
the amount of Devastation both in terms
of uh human life that's been taken
including civilian life of women and
children over 10,000 children is believe
may now have been killed if you rolate
this to where to the end of Hamas which
is what your mission statement is to
eradicate Hamas these numbers are going
to get to catastrophic levels and leave
nothing left in Gaza are
they I disagree first of all the numbers
are Hamas numbers and and have to be
taken with a grain of salt Kamas would
have you believe that you know the
overwhel kill with respect so so are
your numbers you don't know you've
killed 9,000 Hamas terrorists can I tell
you when we've made a mistake with
numbers we we've corrected ourselves you
don't know you've killed 9 and a half
thousand do you you can't that is that
is that that that is the intelligence
information that we have we think that's
an accurate number it could be more it
could be less but that's I mean people
are always asking us for our numbers if
we don't provide them people say what
are you hiding well how how many these
are the best numers okay just to push
you on that if you can be that precise
about the number of Hamas terrorists you
must also know how many civilians you've
killed so how many civilians do you
believe you've killed no but it's it's a
little more complicated if if a Hamas
fighter is wearing civilian clothes is
he civilian if he's a 17-year-old man
with an AK-47 a 17y old boy I should say
with an AK-47 is he a child or is he a
combatant in other words Hamas plays
with the numbers they want you to
believe that they're all children
they're all women uh no Israel does not
Target innocent civilians Israel does
not Target gaza's civilian population we
target Hamas now have there been a uh
civilians caught up in the crossfire
between the Israel Defense Forces and
the Kamas of course there have there
hasn't been a a war in history without
unfortunately people being caught up in
the crossfire without civilian
casualties but are we making in Israel
an effort to avoid that of course we are
for us every civilian death that's a
tragedy but for Hamas who deliberately
uses Gaza civilians as human Shields
it's not a tragedy it's their strategy
they deliberately embed themselves under
schools under hospitals in civilian
neighborhoods even under un fa let me
let me how does this war end you to only
today you had dozens of family members
of hostages held by Hamas still well
over a hundred being held storming into
a finance committee meeting in the
knesset in Jerusalem shouting you won't
sit here while they are dying there so
nearly half of those hostages have still
not been uh brought back you've only
killed by your own figure
you've killed a quarter of Hamas
terrorists so three quarters are still
there your mission statement is to
eradicate Hamas um the infrastructure of
Northern Gaza has been pretty much
obliterated similar thing is now
happening in the South so again I just
ask you what does what does Victory look
like how do you know when you've won
this war how does the world
know so in in the northern part of the
Gaza STP we've already destroyed hamas's
ability to organize in uh to operate in
large scale military formations we've
destroyed their battalions we've
destroyed their brigades you still have
the Odd Squad or two that can cause
problems but as an organized military
force Kamas does not exist in the
northern Kaur strip in the coming weeks
we will achieve the same uh victory in
the center and the South and then we'll
move into a campaign of counterterrorism
of counterinsurgency because ultimately
Hamas will be defeated as a military
machine and Gaza will be free of Hamas
as a ruling power and I've said this
before we simply cannot live next to
this Terror Enclave just as you wouldn't
want to live next to some sort of Isis
caliphate on your border we refuse to
live next to thisas Terror State on ours
Barack who ran Israel says for around
three months now prime minister Benjamin
n has prevented discussion of the day
after in the inner cabinet this is
unconscionable the IDF cannot optimize
the probability of winning when there is
no defined political goal the absence of
a realistic goal will end up m in the
Gaza Quagmire fighting simultaneously in
Lebanon and in the West Bank eroding the
American backing endangering the Abraham
Accords and the peace agreements with
Egypt and with Jordan this kind of
conduct drags Israel security into the
abyss and he says this when prime
minister netanyahu's approval ratings
are languishing in the early 30s which
is similar to President Biden's in
America and is believed to be the lowest
number of any incumbent president who's
ever had to run for reelection so these
are bad numbers you know have former
Prime Ministers of the country demanding
the Netanyahu resign um I suppose the
obvious question is why hasn't he I mean
would it not be easier for everybody if
he stepped aside now and let somebody
new come in and try to guide this to a
conclusion which can actually
work you know it's interesting because
I'm familiar with the polls that you
site and others but the truth is as
following if you ask Israelis do you
support the war aims as articulated by
the Israeli government which is to have
hamas's military machine destroyed to
bring all the hostages home and to
destroy this this Kamas ruled Enclave on
our South to destroy their political
rule you get overwhelming support from
left to right to center 80 90% of
Israelis I heard today the leaders of
the Israeli labor party they they
propose no confidence in the government
over economic issues but they don't
propose no confidence on the the the
waging of the war and the war aims on
the contrary Israeli Society is United
that Kamas must be destroyed as a
political and military force and you can
understand why because when Kamas
crossed the border on October 7th and
started killing us they didn't ask us if
we supported Nan or we opposed him if
we're left or right if we're religious
or secular if we supported judicial
reform or opposed judicial Kamas just
killed everyone they found and I think
for Israelis we have our passionate
debates in this country just as you have
in Britain and people having democracy
around the world of course we have our
passionate political debates But
ultimately I think October 7th was a
moment when Israelis understood you know
we have enemies and there are people
young soldiers now fighting in Gaza
against Kamas some of them are leftwing
some of them are rightwing they're of
different political opinions but we
understand as a country we have to get
this done Kamas must be destroyed it
must be removed from power we must do
everything that we can to get the
hostages home you always get sent out Mr
regev to defend Israel and you do so
every time and I give you credit for
that uh Benjamin Netanyahu despite
repeated requests from this program to
do another interview I interviewed him
in March um nothing hasn't given a
single interview to a non-american uh
television network is it not time that
he answers some tough questions
himself well he's answering tough
questions every week to the Israeli
media which you know is is just as tough
as the British Media or or the American
Media he's been doing these regular
press conferences and asking answering
Jour journalist questions but ultimately
I mean he he's focused today on winning
the war and he's I see him going in and
out of War cabinet meetings and that
this is the big picture because
ultimately it's important that people
understand what Israel is doing and why
we're doing it no I understand that but
number important thing is to win yeah
but he's given important thing is to win
he's found time to give interviews to
American Media I think he should give
one to European media I would just like
to once again given that you do come on
every time that we ask you and I give
you credit again for doing that if you
could just pass on on that request and I
think he
should I promise to pass on the request
sir thank you good to talk to you m r I
appreciate it on S next is there any
hope left then for a two-state solution
with Benjamin Netanyahu in charge
Mustafa bouti and Douglas Murray return
to debate that
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and on your smart
speaking criminals to using XL Bully
dogs as weapons to threaten others no
matter how well trained most dog owners
will tell you a dog can turn you know
what I love about talk today we do it
all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and Rich soon at the
other s starma is about to help make
children even taller
now go that's what's going to happen if
you vote
labor Long Live JK Rowling and her right
to stand up for women but you can only
pity those who despise her
straightforward Politics as somehow
dangerous the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by as to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 44
million so far so40 million so far
results nil absolutely nil Kevin O
Sullivan is the worst presenter on talk
TV sitting on his fat
talkit like brought to you by St KH the
mayor of London vought us with our own
money the the mayor's fireworks very
rarely meet anybody that says you know
the thing about London is it's got a
great mayor it's a deep Cal brilliant
Guy this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film stop creating
all of these funny little factions with
their funny little names the new
conservatives the ERG the common sense
research group the red wool red trouser
popcorn I mean popcorn what what is that
I just cannot see if richy suak goes
does what David Frost what Lord Frost
wants him to do and go further to the
right on taxes and immigration that that
would turn around the what's predicted
by this poll in a landslide Donald Trump
didn't just win
he obliterated this is a guy facing
nearly a 100 criminal charges and yet
all that's done is actually make him
more popular Trump is canny enough to
know that all publicity is good
publicity I don't want a president who's
been impeached if he's able to bamboozle
you that's the way it goes I did my 6
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down and persisted and car
when I say I am God I'm not joking did
you feel Elvis was controlling I've been
answering your question question you
answer mine it's actually not my job to
answer your questions I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group your
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV it's the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
welcome back to p on sensor after
doubling down on his rejection of a
two-state solution and pandering to
hardliners in his party as Israeli Prime
Minister Netanyahu given up on peace and
should the rest of the world give up on
the two-state solution as long as he
remains in power join man to debate this
is the author of the war on the west
Murray and the Palestinian national
initiative leader Mustafa bouti Mr bouti
let me start with you your reaction to
my interview there with Mark
regev
well my reaction is that Mr Riv speaks
about Palestinians have to give up give
up what I don't understand and he wants
peace he wants security without ending
the Israeli occupation he ignores the
basic facts which is that Israel has
conducted ethnic cleansing against 70%
of the Palestinian people forcing them
to become refugees and is depriving them
from coming home for all these 75 years
second is ignoring that Israel is
conducting the longest occupation in
modern history 56 years of occupation of
West Bank and Gaza he's ignoring the
fact that we are all suppressed by
Israel not only in Gaza but also in the
West Bank we are being killed in the
Gaza Strip he speak he he speaks about
the that the numbers of of victims is
incorrect I mean this is very silly
because I think the health Ministry has
issued the name Nam of everybody that is
killed with their ID numbers and their
age and everything so unfortunately
unfortunately what we've heard is the
same thing that Israel has been doing
for all the last 75 years repeating the
same thing and expecting different
results A very wise Jewish
Man by the name of Albert Einstein
Einstein said some said something very
wise he said it is absolutely in it is
Insanity to keep repeating the same
thing and expect different results well
actually isra think actually I can tell
you he didn't actually say that but it's
a it's a quote often ascribed to him but
the point is there Douglas Murray the
point is correct okay I'll take the
point he didn't there's no record of him
ever saying it let let me ask you
Douglas about this you and I debated
this a lot you have a very firm position
completely uh behind Israel which I
completely understand there's anything
that's going on now in terms of the
withdrawal of so much support now from
allies of Israel does any of it give you
pause for thought about how this
actually ends because I'm not sure the
Israeli government knows how this ends
and that concerns
me well I think the Israeli government
knows better than most people certainly
most pundits about how it might end um I
think that there are several things I
have to say in reply to Mr barouti by
the way first of all when I was on this
show last with Mr barouti uh he said
that he hadn't said something he said
and we actually had to issue a
confirmation on the program subsequently
that he had in fact said the words that
he had denied saying but that had come
out of his M mouth praising the
so-called Martyrs um let me say two
other things firstly on the question of
the West Bank frankly in Israel there
are very few people very few people in
Israel who believe that even if you can
have a two-state solution now is a good
time to talk about it I was in the
knesset the the parliament earlier today
and among other people saw the head of
the leftwing opposition Mr laid he
doesn't believe this is a time to speak
about a two-state solution why because
if you gave a state to the Palestinians
and don't forget Israel did give a state
to the Palestinians in 2005 in the Gaza
and look what we got from it uh the
world got its money ransacked uh the
Hamas leaders making themselves
fantastically rich and then sending
Rockets into Israel so the first thing
is even the most left-wing figures in
Israeli politics don't think this is a
good time to talk about the two-state
solution because among other things it
would suggest that there was a reward
for the terrorists of October the 7th
and the reward for the actions of that
day was to double down on giving the
Palestinians yet another state the
second thing that has to be said about
that if I may is on the subject of the
West Bank if you go to the West Bank as
I was again the other night and if you
stand in the Hills overlooking Israel
you will see from those Hills the lights
of Tel Aviv the city I'm standing in at
the moment you will see the lights of he
and you'll see the lights of benorian
airport now knowing what Israel knows
about what Hamas did with the Gaza
making it into a military infrastructure
and firing rockets at Southern and
Central Israel why on Earth would the
Israelis give another piece of territory
which they didn't have security over in
the West Bank to another Palestinian
faction which would have the ability to
fire similar rockets at every single
part of Israel and I need to add one
other thing quickly on the subject of
the Palestinian author auth many people
outside Israel seem to think that the
Palestinian Authority is as it were the
Peaceable wing of Hamas or is the sort
of shin faine to hamas's Ira that is not
the case the Palestinian Authority as
well as being a deeply corrupt entity
which I don't need to tell Mr barouti
about he knows well about that as well
as being a deeply corrupt entity the
Palestinian Authority that is funded by
the Israelis as well as the Europeans
the British and the rest of the
International Community pays salaries to
terrorists it pays salaries to the
people who kill people in Israel and
that is something absolutely impossible
to make peace with I just heard Mr
barouti use the word disgusting so Mr
barouti over to you it is disgusting it
Is disg Well Mr govern Mr Morgan I think
you have to be fair you can't bring Mark
R and give him like 10 or 15 minutes and
then bring another pro-israeli and make
him sh the time with me you have to be
fair in giving me enough time because
what we've just heard is absolutely
rubbish absolutely rubbish just
repeating Israeli propaganda just
repeating faults and and I don't agree
with him that he has verified what I
said I don't agree with him totally and
he is repeating the same aggressive and
fascist speech they don't want two
states what do they want to do with the
7 million people Palestinian 7 million
Palestinians live on the land of
historic Palestine equal to the number
of Jewish people what is the solution
they don't want two State solution fine
let's have one Democratic state with
equal rights for everybody but no
Netanyahu and his fascist government he
has fascist in his government he has
smotrich and Bing ver who call
themselves fascist these people don't
want to see a two-state solution don't
want to see one Democratic state so
their solution is exactly what they are
trying to do in Gaza now which is
genocide and ethnic cleansing genocide
it is genocide what's happening because
we are talking about 32,000 Palestinian
people killed including those under the
rebel and 64,000 people injured 63,000
people injured that is 4% of the
population if that had happened in the
United States of America you would be
talking about 12 million people killed
or injured is that acceptable okay is it
is it not that Israel is occupying the
West Bank isn't the United States of
America saying that there is occupation
okay says there is occupation I hear you
I'm going to go back to Douglas so erra
mvis the UK's Chief Rabbi has said that
using the word genocide to describe
Israel's actions in Gaza is an
increasingly frequent disingenuous
misappropriation of the term he said the
use of a term was a moral inversion
which undermines the memory of the worst
crimes in human history and designed to
tear open the still gaping wounds of the
Holocaust oh Douglas we can't hear you I
don't know if you can hear me but we
can't hear
you there might be a sound I got you
back I
think okay
um let me just say can you hear me now
pleas yes I can hear you can you hear me
now let me just quickly say this about
the genocide thing of course that's the
case Mr vgti likes to throw around the
word fascist fine I'll throw it back at
you Mr barouti not just a fascist but an
apologist for terrorists fine we can all
throw around slurs at each other but
more important is the fact that you said
that I had told lies unlike you I don't
tell lies I'll tell you why I'll tell
you why unlike you unlike you I don't
speak out of two sides of my mouth I'm
speaking out of one side of my mouth and
it's direct at you so let me just
correct what you just said you said what
I said were lies unfortunately for you I
have here with me the amended
Palestinian prisoners law of 20 4 now
mmud abas who now runs the Palestinian
Authority signed this into law this
means that and I'm quoting article two
here prisoners anyone incarcerated in
the occupation prisons for his
participation in the struggle against
the occupation will be given a salary by
the let me finish my point will be given
a salary by the Palestinian Authority oh
you think they're Freedom Fighters well
let me tell you another couple of things
then because everyone watching pays
their taxes and some of their taxes go
to the Palestinian Authority here's the
budget the Palestinian Authority in 2018
this is the PA's own budget Mr barouti
so don't lie about that
$162 million was allocated to the
prisoners and released prisoners
Ministry in in in 2018 in 2018
approximately $193 million was given by
the PA to families of the martyrs there
is an increasing list depending on how
many Jews you've killed of the amount of
money you get is the Palestinian
Authority doing that or not Mr barouti
because I have their budget in my hand
okay Mr bouti out of respect for
fairness answer that
question yeah but uh I I'm sure your
guest has to be a bit polite you can't
keep saying you can answer that one
question well I will answer it yes they
they support the prisoners families they
support as form of Social Security
support they support the I mean nobody
even if you consider even even if you
consider somebody is is doing something
wrong you cannot punish his children and
his wife in an act of collective
punishment this is salar the people who
do the terror as you well know Mr you
said something wrong also Palestinian
Authority really does not I don't defend
the Palestinian Authority but I'm
telling you 90% of the Palestinian
Authority budget comes from taxpayers
from Palestinian people and only 10%
isra government and contrary no no no no
and Israel is p connect committing
piracy stealing our taxpayers money
preventing health educ health people
from getting their salaries preventing
the Palestinian Authority from you you
shut up please let me answer can you
shut up don't interrupt me please well
you don't be interrupting you each time
you speak you shut up you are not the
one who is asking me the questions
you're not the Anor so shut up please
and let me answer I am saying what you
are trying to do here is to mislead the
discussion ask I I'm the main discussion
here is is there Israeli occupation of
Palestinian land or not if people are
occupied what does international law
says International says law say law says
that people who are under occupation
have the right to struggle against their
occupiers that's what the UN says you
can't devate you can't deviate the
discussion and the the the main fact
here is that the problem we have is that
Israel is occupying Palestinian land and
Israel is oppressing Palestinian people
since 1967 Israel conducted 1 million
arrests against the 7 million people who
are living there how could this be
acceptable what we see here is the wor
most
difficult just to be clear I am I am
just to be clear I am the Anor okay I Am
The Anchor and I'm now going to let
Douglas respond to that
Douglas two things first of all Mr talks
about the
isra Mr speak Please
Mr Mr bti doesn't want
mrti let Douglas Murray respond don't
talk over him yeah okay fine
Please Mr barouti doesn't want a two
State solution because he doesn't want a
Jewish State he wants the river to the
sea to be a Palestinian state ruled by
him and his corrupt friends but secondly
he cannot answer the question I've put
to him repeatedly this is the PA budget
it rewards terrorism and let me just
finish Mr barouti since I allowed you
that right in the end this budget not
only extends to rewarding the people who
carry out acts of terrorism against Jews
and the families of people who do thus
incentivizing Terror and that's a
Palestinian Authority the Palestinian
Authority has also now the Palestinian
Authority has also now committed to pay
salaries to the fighters and the
terrorists of Hamas from October the 7th
and their families so tell me please
peers or Mr barouti where is the good
negotiating partner on the Palestinian
side here exactly well I tell you I tell
you what I'm going to do I'm going to
wrap this by saying this I don't think
there is a good negotiating party on
either side I don't think you can
possibly have peace with Hamas still in
place I don't think we're going to
achieve peace with Benjamin n yahu in
charge of Israel uh and his Hardline
Whitewing cabinet so if you want my
honest view I think we need a completely
clean room of leadership um and that's
the only way is ever going to get
resolved but I appreciate you both for
coming on together and debating it
passionately thank you both for your
time Mr barouti Mr Murray I appreciate
it and since next a New Rising Star in
women's golf who once again you guessed
it used to be a biological man my Pat
takes a swing of that in a
moment
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online we're
on your smart speaker as well you know
what I love about talk today we do it
all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with braan she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other the
police are pro Palestine that is just
not right you swearing off in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes wrong unexpected item
in bagging area I know are we only going
to be trusting sources like meta and
Google where is our unbiased news going
to come from at Graham was president of
the Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the
Oxford Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegans about Twitter you sons of can
you please reinstate my account thank
you this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth
[Music]
this is talk
TV a very exciting moment because I've
rejoined with my old pack for the first
time this year talk TV contributor
Esther kru so of daily M Kevin Maguire
journalist Ava Santina have you missed
me yeah yeah don't lie
um we're gonna start U just to promote
something that's coming up we're going
to show a little bit of a great
interview I've done with the
astrophysicist Neil de grass Tyson did
it in New York last week he's one of the
great minds of the world talking
specifically about AI that will all be
available on our PI organiz YouTube
channel uh well worth a watch is about
35 40 minutes I think we're going to
show a little bit of it after the pack I
to give you a flavor but well worth
watching that later right let's start
with Kia starm who's clearly in the box
seat now to get reelected unless
something extraordinary happens which it
might well do um he issued a woke
warning Val back woke charity said as he
waited into culture wars um he's been on
about this for a while Kevin saying he
thinks this woke stuff is all culture
wars stuff your thoughts look he's back
the National Trust and the rnli the
Lifeboat charity two of the most trusted
bodies in in Britain I think it's a
no-brainer from him because most people
think the cost of living what's
happening to the health Service public
services law and disorder they're all
more important issues he said very
little about this in the past he's run
away from it but he's all of a sudden
seen an opportunity because I think
people are fed up with divisions and
particularly attacks on National Trust
has got 5 million P they're all fed up
with the woke nonsense well yes and I
think the thing is trying to categorize
it all as kind of insignificant culture
War cultur stuff I think does it a
disservice as what's been going on well
this is the thing I think he shouldn't
have said anything actually CU he's he's
picking a battle he cannot win and
ultimately this man has the luxury of
believing that this is just cultur War
stuff it doesn't really affect people
there is a reason why people are getting
upset about this there is a reason why
when the leader of the opposition
doesn't want to say what a woman is or
can't define IT people get upset if you
don't want to talk about or address it
fine but don't effectively turn your
nose up at people who take this
important yes the cost of living crisis
is very important but also so is kids
education so is what what by the way so
so is so is fairness and equality in
women's sport and I'll bring a in here
uh the the nxxt women's classic mission
in Resort in the United States uh Haley
Davidson has just managed to sorry I've
got the 100 day cough has managed to
secure her spot on the prestigious
women's Epson Tour all sounds perfectly
fine until you realize she's a
biological male Adam app right and I
want to play a clip from Caitlyn Jenner
who used to be Bruce Jenner who won the
Olympic gold cathon and plays a lot of
golf this is what Caitlyn said to me
about this I play a lot of golf yeah and
at at our club I mean I play with the
women a lot by the way pierce the women
are a lot more fun to play with than the
men but the conversation's much better
but they always ask you know say hey
we've got a tournament coming up yeah
we've got a tournament coming up you
want to play with us and you know when
I'm there I say oh that would be fun but
then I never show up why because it's
just honestly it's I don't I would never
want to take a trophy away from one of
the other I love the ladies at our club
they're wonderful I wouldn't want to
take I can outd dve him by 100 yard my
arms are longer I'm 61 so it just
wouldn't be fair wouldn't be fair so why
are we allowing it why aren't women
screaming from the rooftops at this
constant erosion of their rights in
sport which K St would doubtless
categorize as culture wars I feel sorry
for this this golf player because I
think that she's been put into a tricky
position where she is clearly excellent
at the SPO and that she has not been
accommodated so she's not able to
phant theit Jenner justly articulated
here's a picture of this transgender
golfer let's be a little bit careful
about Caitlyn Jenner because I guess the
second or third who were biological
women let's be bit careful because
Caitlyn Jenner I mean as a big fan of
keeping up with Kardashians and all of
it she does have some inra misogyny as
we we used to see with with Bruce
actually she stands up for women's
rights more than many women look I'm
look I'm a big believer in women's
rights but I will agree with you on I
will say I will agree with you on K sta
so I this big speech today that he gave
on culture War I thought it was very
fluffy I thought it was a bit weak it
didn't have any substance to it if you
are going to come out and condemn the
culture war and say that you don't want
to get involved in the war and woke then
you need to be strong in your conviction
and I don't think K dama has de decided
where he is on the trans discussion
where he is is he in La is he not we
don't know and I think he realizes
middle England is not having any of this
by the way and doesn't view it as
culture War they see it as an actual
attack on rights to fairness and
equality and do you not think that
voters would would like to see strength
in conviction so if he came out and he
said I am a trans Ally Then you know
where he
stands like you saying you can support
trans rights to fairness and equality
right to the point they erode women's
rights to fairness and equality the two
are not incompatible I think that's
where he's gone now and he saw what
happened in Scotland with nich sturgeon
when you had a a rapist who raped in way
only I want look I want I want to segue
into uh two political candidates of one
in the states one here uh the one here
is Susan Hall is a Conservative
candidate to be mayor of this great City
one of the great jobs in politics in the
world right this was her interview with
my great mate Nick Ferrari on LBC today
which she's just so to early I have to
play a bit of it for you how much do you
pay to get on a bus currently I don't
use them I use trains all the time you
don't know what a bus fair is no who
owns the bridge it's not very clear so
you're saying that the two local
authorities shouldn't have to bear the
whole cost and people who live in sidcup
and Highgate should have to pay to
repairing Hammer Smith bridge but what's
the starting salary um I don't I don't
know what the one is now they're being
given a 5% oh I probably should know
what nurses earn and teachers earn
£36,000 you did initially think the 2020
election was stolen no I I did I never
intended to go to go into this sort of
level of politics if not I probably
would not have had a Twitter account I
mean it just went on and on and on that
was kind that was kind that was a bit
where she was asked whether uh sadik
Khan is right to try and um give um
young people in London Visa in Europe
well it was a moronic answer you should
say no we want to keep our talents
doesn't even know which council is in
charge of the Hammer Smith brid Hami
ofen honly was two
cils but here his point though I mean
look you're a conservative how have the
Tories come up with this absolute CL as
a c if I'm Sadi KH I'm rubbing my hands
yeah what talented person would want to
to join the conservative party right now
this look at the Cal look at the caliber
of of the government vot for you over
her well they don't enough Sor I I I'll
vote enthusiastically for S Sadi KH but
if he and
Esther but if he was going to construct
an opponent to beat it would be Suz
because she's in charge or would be in
charge of Transport she would be in
charge of the didn't know what police
get paid didn't know what a bus fa was
doesn't know who runs the bridges she
didn't have a Scooby-Doo
AA talking of which a campaigns that
have gone up in smoke Ron the the
sanctimonious uh as Donald Trump used to
call him was now he's now retired the
nickname after Dan santis pulled out the
American presidential race I thought Dan
santis was going to be the guy well I
thought he was picturing himself as the
you know the sort of Trump without the
baggage it turns out no none of these
Republicans could stop the Trump train I
he is running them all over I think a
lot of his donors expected that he would
have at least you know slightly competed
with him can you imagine if you're one
of the people who sank Millions into
this you maybe the problem out I think
his team more than anything else this is
actually what they made him say in his
resignation
Video Winston Churchill once remarked
that Success is Not final failure is not
fatal it is the courage to continue that
counts just one problem judge will never
said it I mean it's a bit like that
quote from Einstein about he never said
that either these things do get gather
their own momentum would have said stay
there he was like we will not flag and
like I'm in the
to here's a question here's a question
for you you lefties over here um I used
to be but I'm too I'm now rightwing
because I don't like the woke stuff
right and and that's now you're seeing a
real movement in America Bill Mah and
other people like that who don't
identify really to the left anymore
because it's moved so far we're now seen
to be conservatives you'll come back
you'll come back I don't see any way
Trump doesn't get the nomination now for
which is an amazing comeback whatever
you think it's incredible but ALS Al I
don't really see any way a doy
apparently half dead Joe Biden beats him
and stops him getting back in the White
House no but but of course you know
Trump himself was pretty doy he confused
Nikki Hy with nanc come
off but I agree at the moment if I'd put
my 20p my my 10 cents on a trump
presidency which I do
not yeah I mean I think the big question
is for British conservatives who align
themselves with that side of politics
this is going to be a really trying time
for them because they're now going to
have to think about their foreign policy
particularly how are we're going to fund
Ukraine in the coming weeks or coming
months if Trump is to get into the White
House that money is not going to Ukraine
anymore you know what I I watched the
head of JP Morgan Jamie Diamond very
interesting last week gave an interview
to Fox I think he was he said the thing
about Trump is his supporters they're
not all these whack jobs that they're
being painted all the time they actually
think he did a pretty good job on the
economy he was tough on immigration the
southern borders out of control they
thought his foreign policy was pretty
sound he didn't go to war anywhere they
actually put the rhetoric to one side
and like what what he did just thing and
he made a very good point you cannot
demonize 70 million Americans there
there is a reason why they're choosing
him over the The Walking Corpse that is
Joe Biden you have to give credit where
credit is due quick question who's going
to win the US election I reckon Trump
Trump trump at the moment he did set up
a war you're wrong there Trump but he
did set up a war he planned he planned
the withdrawal of from Afghanistan who's
going to win the election Trump's going
to win the election Trump Trump trump
Trump trump unbelievable the come back
of a century s said next thank you p uh
the astrophysicist Neil degrass Tyson
returns to give us his big brain Cosmic
perspectives on artificial intelligence
War and the Art of folding laundry
that's after the
[Music]
break we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and we're on your smart speaking
criminals to useing XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about support today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the tor's love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the
other sec mama is about to help make
children even taller
now go that's what's going to happen if
you vote
labor Long Live JK Rowling and her right
to stand up for women we can only pity
those who despise her straightforward
Politics as somehow
dangerous the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million P so far so40 million pound so
far results nil absolutely nil Kevin O
Sullivan is the worst presenter on talk
TV sitting on his
fat like brought to you by Steve KH the
mayor of London bought us with our own
money the the mayor's fireworks very
rarely meet anybody that says you know
the thing about London is he got a great
mayor it's a deep C brilliant
Guy this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film
stop creating all of these funny little
factions with their funny little names
the new conservatives the ERG the common
sense research group the red wool red
trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what what
is that I just cannot see if Rishi suac
goes does what David Frost what Lord
Frost wants him to do and go further to
the right on taxes and immigration that
that would turn around the what's
predicted by this poll in a landslide
Donald Trump didn't just win he
obliterated this is a guy facing nearly
a 100 criminal charges and yet all
that's done is actually make him more
popular Trump is canny enough to know
that all publicity is good publicity I
don't want a president who's been
impeached if he's able to bamboozle you
or that's the way up but did my 6 months
I came back nobody would touch me I put
my head down and persisted and carried
on when I say I am God I'm not joking
did you feel Elvis was controlling I've
been answering your question you answer
mine it's actually not my job to answer
your questions I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV it's the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that coming up tonight on the
independent republic of Mike grman it's
extraordinary Story a tale of diplomatic
conversations taking place between
Chinese Communist party members and a
British piano player apparently didn't
like the fact that he was filming them
at St panr station it's an extraordinary
tale you won't quite believe your ears
just like the independent republic of
Mike gr every night don't miss it coming
up right after Piers Morgan
[Music]
9:00 welcome back to unsensed Astro
visitors Neil degrass Tyson's one of the
planet's brightest Bings when he comes
looking out at the night sky and making
sense of it all in his new book staring
Messengers however degrass Tyson says
himself a new challenge taking a cosmic
perspective on problems and issues
facing human civilization here on Earth
I sat down with him to find out more
great to see you thanks for here on your
side of the pond yes yes uh you've got
another brilliant Bookout Starry
Messenger uh Cosmic perspectives on
civilization yeah as always I have to
ask you of the just released in
paperback just just week ago I think I
talked to you when when the hardback
came out just in a nutshell for those
who haven't read this or any ofal stuff
what is the simple normal person's
version of what this is about things
look different from a cosmic perspective
and I think I I I quote Apollo 14
astronaut Edgar Mitchell in this book he
looked back and he
said you develop an instant Global
consciousness a people orientation an
intense dissatisfaction with the state
of the world and a compulsion to do
something about it from out there on the
moon International politics looks so
petty you want to grab a politician by
the Scruff of the neck and drag him a
quarter million miles out and say look
at that you son of a
can I say that absolutely this is
uncensored this is uncens you just did
so so he was feeling the cosmic
perspective when you're that high up you
don't see the national borders you and
we're just one species down there on
this on this spaceship earth alone in
the darkness of the universe with no
hint that help will come from elsewhere
to save us from ourselves as Carl San
had poetically referenced and so you you
you're changed and so what I attempt in
this book is to take places where we
have arguments over holiday dinners when
the uncles and cousins and aunts come in
and say what would that look like like
from a cosmic perspective and half of
those arguments evaporate in that
instant because like what are you
fighting about like really can't you see
why we are more the same than different
you don't see that because our tribal
urges will pick every little thing that
you can possibly say is different is
your skin differently reflective of
sunlight than mine well let's make a big
deal of that do you worship different
gods or no gods or any let's make a big
deal of that oh oh you sleep with this
person in this instead of that person of
our own species let's make a big deal of
that why are we so flawed human beings I
think that feature mattered to our
survival 100,000 years ago 50,000 years
ago because you don't know if another
group that showed up on the horizon will
they harm you take your resources or not
you don't know that but you do know that
other people in your tribe they smell
like you they kind look like you and
it's easy to distinguish them from the
others so that may have had survival
value 50 100,000 years today when we
have civilization and society and our
intellect to know and understand our DNA
it's it's quite I don't want to call it
childish well yeah okay I'm going to say
it that it this tribalism in the world
feels childish to me it's what what
would an alien say they come say oh
you're all the same species you say yeah
yeah okay um and you're fighting for
these reasons but you're the same
species right what are you what are you
doing why and then they'll run home and
Report there's no sign of intelligent
life on
Earth just saying I did the last thing I
mentioned to you before in a previous
interview I did the last television
interview with Professor Steven Hawking
and it was a fascinating insight into
that remarkable brain that he had but
one question really stuck with me and
one answered did I said to him what is
in your estimation the biggest threat to
Mankind and he said when artificial
intelligence learns to self-design just
consider that right now ai is basically
everywhere there's no tech company that
isn't fully exploiting the value of AI
to their business model in my field
which is not even a corporate entity
it's just science in my field
astrophysics we've been using AI at any
possible point that it could Advance us
we use it and we've been using it for
decades why aren't you terrified of it
because you're very positive about AI
let me okay there are people who will
read you the riot act about the future
of AI and many of them are deep in the
field so I'm not here to undo their
concerns all I would tell you is AI in
its sort of restricted form where I have
a task I don't want to do it let a
machine do it and let's teach it and
have it machine learn what it is I need
it to do and have it do it that's kind
of how AI has ested in society why do
you not fear that AI can become
genuinely sentient and start making
decisions completely on its own yeah it
depends you can make a decision but how
much power are you going to Grant it all
right if we we I mean look I don't want
to put words in your mouth here and I
certainly don't compare my brain to
yours however my my simple mind my
simple mind says to me that as with the
internet as with all great new
Innovations but particularly with AI
given its enormous power I can
absolutely see all the positives
especially in science in medicine all
these things and there's an existential
risk on the other side of that how are
you not as scared as I'm about that yeah
so I think any technological Advance has
always had a dark side in the hands of
Nefarious actors so I don't yes AI poses
an existential risk so too did nuclear
weapons right so so to do weapons in
general all right and so uh I was on a
on a on a um on a a board that served
the Pentagon uh a defense Innovation
board it was and we confronted this
issue with AI in the military and we
arrived at a the conclusion that if a
kill decision has to be made a human
being needs to be in that Loop you
cannot have ai make that decision
without a human being participating in
it recognizing that AI is inevitable in
the in the in that world world and so
but you want to put in some constraints
and yes this is not the Rogue actor
right these are rational people making
these decisions well you can watch a
full uncut version of that interview
with n grass Tyson on our P Morgan
uncensored YouTube channel right now
become a subscriber while you're there
and join 2.3 million others that's it
for me whatever you're up to make sure
it is
uncensored good
night
[Music]
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online we're
on your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costumes
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about talk today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the tor's love a scrap you can
almost see this coming round the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sinak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police are pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear in O in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have have a
message for Sadi Khan we're not stopping
until you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy should I mean he's got
house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz Phil